et comment allez-vous bienvenue dans mon
salon de tatouage comme vous le savez je
dessine extraordinairement bien j'ai
décidé de dessiner sur la peau des gens
pour bien indiquer le restant de leur
vie aujourd'hui et sur ten seconde
tatoué vous savez en 2016 les gens sont
extrêmement pressé il faut que tout
aille vite et soit immédiat et du coup
même les tatouages noir tatoué en 10
secondes mordelles c'est parti premier
client je veux un robot patriotes
ok ce parti un robot ça c'est un robot
c'est bendtner de futurama ok et là on
va marquer vive la france aux attentes
autant je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
on n'est pas dans le thème mais on a
quand même fait petit biscuit de shrek
si tu veux le côté patriote revient
demain je rajouterais un arbre la france
et ça fera 2 s'emballe ok suivant un
loup démoniaque
alors en fait c'est une main qui fait
l'ombre du loup ça c'est la lumière et
du coup l'om ça fait un loup ici rien
hop voilà théâtre à l'essai de ruiner ma
vie alors le pénis de profils s'était
pas voulu assumer mon père mais je sais
pas pourquoi mon imagination ne me
permet pas de faire débuter bon dessin
par koné bon tatouage ça ça va suivant
les six mois une glace personnaliser une
glace alors c'est hyper sabres regarde
ça c'est le bâtonnet ça c'est la glace
hockey et au dessus on va faire de la
mer c'est la mer à dans la mer en bleus
voilà et la glace on appelle à isbergues
comme ça avec la mère seraient un jeu de
mots
j'arrive pas à imaginer comment ça
aurait pu être pire
1 2 c'est comme ça tu vas te calmes et
sur la prochaine fois je vais tâter la
pupille mon pote tu la verras tous les
jours tu as glace hockey suivant heini
de tuning quoi tu t'es sûr de pas bien
précisément ce que tu veux ok mon pote
on va décider des piercings un anneau
vif a déjà un peu de barbossi parce que
là c'est totalement manque de marne et
on en a qui tourne et au peintre et un
maire dans les connais faut jamais
blagues et de bon sens de coiffure
dessine moi un dauphin meurtrier watts
donc ça c'est le dauphin ok ça c'est le
l'aileron du dauphin et finalement c'est
un oeuf au plat dans une poêle qui est
en train de cuire voilà ce qu'on a fait
oh ouais il est cool bah ouais faut
faire confiance mon gars suivant [ __ ]
on a envie de respecter les règles
d'hygiène à lomé petit gant latex que
les infirmières ont pour pas affecter la
plaie hop on est parti moi j'avais plus
de gants en latex mais c'est pareil il
ya juste un max de dépôt suivis les
charpentes vespa toxiques à lattes à
tous avec des gants mon pote c'est dur
un allié spirituel un esprit étrangers
j'ai mal traduit à j'espère un esprit
étrangers aux potes alors un esprit
étrangers on va faire l'esprit de qui
est étranger au kgb monga hockey en noir
claque
clac voilà ça c'est l'aura spirituelle
de l'esprit de l'offre de tout à leur
travail incroyable [ __ ] vous adorez
les oeufs attachés entre un lancer de
mode sur paris là ça peut être bizarre
mais tu devrais faire un
hélas rien dit on va bien s'occuper de
tonka mon pote
hop hop hop sans shido voilà on tape un
banal faire mon pote i'm ahidous je
passerai si ça veut dire que les sites
mois une authentique carte hockey
tatouage il va te coûter un bras mon
patin ok c'est parti hop hop hop hop 2 2
2 voilà je t'ai fait une carter stone je
t'ai fait le lanceur de couteaux il
coûte 2000 à 2 2 voilà soient prises et
la prochaine fois parce que oui la règle
d'or dans mon merveilleux salon tatouage
c'est le respect envers le client nous
respectent un soin qu'est ce qu'on va se
faire en bas des cheveux
voilà ce à quoi de faire [ __ ] quelle
bonne idée mon pote pourquoi tu y as pas
pensé avant voit les mêmes et même un
double sourcils voilà incroyable travail
on est styliste à mi temps on va pas se
mentir je veux un papillon tribales ah
oui ok ok je vois les lire alors ces
genres clac clac clac à des noirs et la
tête et a pas de noirs la baignoire
gagner d'autres comme ça tu comme ça
voilà c'est un peu tribal hop voilà
tribal a tancé sur google on tape tribal
butterfly je sache ça ressemble comme
deux gouttes d'eau au regard des bateaux
mais c'est pas une pâle copie de ce
qu'on vient de faire c'est pas un pur
plagiat un mec capable de copier le land
art qui sort de mon salon tatouage
opusien double sens traire cette oeuvre
d'art on peut aussi voir un visage et ça
c'est beau ça monte que en dessinant le
trottoir a raconté
voyez qu'il a créé un univers autour de
son oeuvre bong acheté en bourse j'ai
attendu ça toute ma vie
un poil voilà ta maman 0 point sur ton
corps il fait une belle tournée au moins
j'aimerais avoir une feuille de cannabis
spirituel mais bien sûr la voilà tu as
fait de cannabis fumer tue parce que
c'est ça va c'est le tatouage c'est
aussi les bons conseils pour aider le
client à walker salzmann
une sacrée maman ça c'est sa tête ok et
la voilà c'est sacré moment là mais on
est un bon morceau doit pas se mitonner
longtemps avec le petit nombril
je vais aller vivre seul dans les bois
bonne idée mais si je perds médecin
passe alors tu serais cta sacré d'abord
j'ai voulu ça toute ma vie
une moustache d'hitler horrible tu dois
être nouveau dans ce métier comment dire
je veux un arc-en-ciel matt schaub n ya
pas de souci hop hop
mais il a une petite moustache en ont
mais là c'est pas normal a pour charge
de métier j'arrive avec la souris makes
impossible j'ai pu mais quand ce pour ça
j'ai pu mais grands hommes leur débours
témoin une machine à écrire alors ça
c'est ma spécialité ça si je puis me
permettre
olalala et à tous d'aller à tous via les
touches du clavier la feuille a4 prête à
recevoir des coups qui imprime les
lettres dessus tu là on va le mettre
dans le livre de dépôt du salon et
j'aimerais avoir un joli drapeau ouais
voilà je finirai longtemps plus simple
c'est fait drapeau ni les poneys avec
des petites couleurs qui vont dans le
rose dans le fluo dans le vois tu kiffes
pas j'aimerais un squelette de bateaux
ok mon pote un max d'hygiène encore plus
d'hygiène on assure la sécurité du salon
c'est parti
ces vidéos sur dix secondes pour faire
de toi je n'hésiterais pas à l'est mais
ça vous a plu et n'hésitez pas à me
contacter et j'aurais mis mes cordes
ever description si vous voulez un
tatouage
voilà tout ce qui est baguette de pain
squelette de bateau je méconnais à la
presse depuis jamais l'inversé avoir
gardé tient du monde portez vous bien en
pis
[Musique]